we would like to praise God for another
day Pastor RIS that he has made that we
should be here to answer some questions
and uh be able to hear What God Says on
these issues would you like to open for
us with the word of prayer surely let's
pray Our Father in heaven we thank you
for the gift of life and we thank you de
God for the high honor of speaking for
you grant to us simple wisdom I pray let
your spirit guide our thinking and our
speaking bless those who listen
Enlighten their understanding dear God
that the knowledge May draw them closer
to you in the name of Jesus Christ we
pray amen
amen the question that opens the
curtains for us today is about the
children of uh Israel and their 40 Years
of wandering in the
wilderness was it God's will or was it
because of their sin
they wandered in the wilderness because
of
unbelief you know the 12 Spies went to
search out the
city uh before before that God had told
them go and take the city we're well
able to take it and they didn't and God
was very pleased they came back with all
kinds of complaints the people were big
they're tall the walls are high we can't
do this and they were scared and they
rebelled against God they complained and
God was very very angry only two men
were positive saying we can take that
City Joshua and Caleb and so God told
them that I will punish you virtually
curse you by allowing you to wander 40
years in the
wilderness a day for each year as a
punishment for your unbelief you know
God wanted to really strike them with a
pestilence and Moses intervened you read
numbers 13 and 14 and so it wasn't God's
will that they Wonder 40 years virtually
going around in circles because of
unbelief they did not enter into the
rest of Canaan land and so it wasn't
God's will but they brought it on
themselves by not trusting God despite
all the things God had done the plagues
in Egypt parting the Red Sea Mana from
Heaven water from a rock all of that
they saw they still didn't believe in
God's ability to work through them to
conqu of the land and so God cursed them
and sent them wandering for 40 years it
wasn't his will so part of this um
discussion would be eventually When God
says you cannot go in and then a few of
them decide that now they want to go in
and God says you
cannot this is part of their unbelief
still not W being willing to be led by
God and rebelling against his desire and
his command when God told them go take
it they
didn't when they realized the anger of
God they decided well we'll go the city
of AI on one occasion and they were
soundly defeated and they came back
crying and weeping and wailing when God
tells us to do something we do it we
don't do it when he does not tell us God
told the Israelites cross the Red Sea he
parted it they crossed safely he did not
tell the the Egyptians to cross they
came Crossing every single one drowned
had the Israelite obeyed God and taken
that city as God told them they would
not have been 40 years in the wilderness
it was P plain and simple
unbelief in the word of God Amen thank
you an unbelief in the word of God is
unbelief in God because you really can't
separate the two MH thank you the next
one is uh on marriage and of marriage
with a nonbeliever
MH in case of a daughter or a son son of
a church leader who get who insists on
getting married to a
nonbeliever what should be the role of
the parent in this whole thing and what
should the church do well that's a very
tough one but truth is truth and right
is right very often obeying God is
tough I'm assuming that the parents had
done everything in their power to raise
their children the right way to know God
to know God requirements for his people
because God consistently told the
Israelites do not intermarry with the
unbelievers don't do that now if your
child decides to rob a bank would you
join the child in committing that crime
the answer is no no then can you join
your child in committing a crime against
God by marrying outside of the faith the
answer has to be no as hard as it is in
Luke chap when the parents of Jesus the
Earthly parents found him in the temple
they said Son why hast thou thus dealt
with us Luke 2:48 thy father and I have
sought The Sorrowing Jesus said how is
it he sought me wished she not that I
must be about my father's business he
was putting the father's business ahead
of his Earthly parents but with respect
the Bible says they did not
understand parents who put God first
ahead of their children let me repeat
that parents who put God ahead of their
children cannot join their children in
violating a principle of God as
difficult as it is you cannot do
that amen the Adventist home page 67
paragraph 1 to connect with an
unbeliever is to place yourself on
Satan's ground you grieve the spirit of
God and forfeit his protection now if
that's the case how can I enter into
that whether it's my my child or not God
comes rigorously first and no
circumstance must alter that Arrangement
even if your child or your spouse or
your cousin or your boss your first
Allegiance is to God and we cannot join
people in sin in this case as you've
well put it the issue is what is God's
will as far as marriage is concerned and
if marriage with an
unbeliever God's will should have no we
can participate in no we shouldn't amen
MH next question is about
tithe someone somebody uh wonders is it
okay for someone or even a local church
to decide to redirect their tithe from a
conference to a different line of
evangelism the church is an organized
body remove organization and you have
disorganization
remove organization you have chaos the
church is a reflection of Heaven because
the church on earth and the church in
heaven are supposed to be one but we
must obey God as verily as the church
above obeys God we have this system of
tithing the Seventh Day Adventist Church
has a system the tithe is returned to
the church the same way the Widow
brought her might to the temple despite
the fact Jesus knew the temple was run
by corrupt priests he Comm he commended
her for bringing her tithe to the church
because the tithe is really given to God
not to the conference president or the
executive secretary or the local church
pastor is given to God we must avoid the
scenario in which every man does what is
right in his own eyes as was accustom in
the Book of Judges and so our policy as
a church is to bring the tithe to the
storehouse the storehouse is a church
now I cannot say that God will not
convict an individual to act differently
on particular occasions I cannot deny
that but if you think God has convicted
you to give it to some organization
don't tell anyone because if you tell
someone you may spread an activity that
by spreading becomes a problem if you
alone did it no problem because you feel
so powerfully convicted but if you
spread the news around that I'm doing
this and I'm doing that simply because
you want to let the church know the
church can't tell tell you what to do we
love to be rebellious then you've
created a problem but the general
practice is the tithe is returned to the
local church and the local church takes
it from there to the conference and
upward there's a system is it a perfect
system no because human beings are
involved but is it a working system
yes the church has benefited yes so we
must avoid everyone doing what he or she
likes the tithe is not the yours it is
God's and God has a church on on
Earth which he put together in the Old
Testament days he had a church in these
days he has a church now it is not
common to talk about the remnant church
as it used to be but God has a Remnant
people on this Earth seventh day
Adventists I don't mean just those who
don't work on Saturday I mean seventh
day
Adventists and they have a system for
giving and that system ought to be
upheld until God shows us a better way
amen
return your tithe to the church if you
decide to give it to some Ministry do
not tell
anyone and you touched on a very
important point that um I want to piggy
back
up somebody may be unfaithful in an
office somewhere that's not an excuse
for me to be unfaithful absolutely if
God has said return TI and offering I
should do my part and let God deal with
the person in
yes
Saul 1st Samuel 16:14 the spirit of God
departed from Saul yet David wouldn't
touch him touch not the Lord's anointed
he wouldn't touch him because he still
occupied that position but the spirit
had left him David knew he was God's
chosen man but David respected Saul the
misbehavior of an officer does not give
me freedom to
misbehave God has a way of dealing with
his church dealing with his people
people he has a way of dealing with
Nations the Israelites were in captivity
to Babylon when they were not treated
the right way God sent Cyrus to deliver
them from the Babylonians even though it
was God who sent them into captivity
Daniel chapter 1 1 and two God knows how
to deal with his church
amen next we have a question about the
difference between the Holy Spirit and
the Holy Ghost is there a difference
there no difference you know in John
14:16 Jesus said and I will pray the
father and he shall give you another
comforter that he may abide with you
forever in verse 26 he says but the
comforter which is the Holy Ghost whom
the father will send in my name so the
comforter is the Holy Ghost but he's
called the spirit of Truth you see so
he's the Holy Ghost he's the Holy Spirit
John
15:26 but when the comforter is come
whom I will send unto you from the
father even the spirit of Truth through
his call the spirit of Truth the holy
ghost or the Holy Spirit same
personality same person the title does
not make a difference the title doesn't
change who he is now amen we have
somebody else who's asking about the
Sumerian tablet the Rosetta Stone and
archology should we place this over the
authority of the Bible absolutely not
nothing takes precedence over God's word
no branch of knowledge can be placed
above God's word let me make a statement
that may outrage some every branch of
knowledge must come under the
supervision of God if there's something
in chemistry that violates God's
principles then that is wrong now the
Bible is not a chemistry book it's not a
history book but if it makes a
historical statement that statement must
be taken as accurate and reliable even
if secular history says something else
that's what I mean by every branch of
knowledge must acknowledge the supremacy
of God's word archaeological discoveries
do not make the Bible true and the
Sumerian Tablets and the Retta Stone
other things they confirm what the Bible
itself already states it is true they
confirm the accuracy and the
truthfulness of God's word they don't
make God's word true and the length of a
thing's existence does not mean it is
reliable you understand so even though
some things were discovered that existed
before the Bible was written that does
not give them authority over God's word
it's not length of time it is the source
and the source of the Bible is God
himself the Holy Ghost and that makes it
authoritative over anything archaeology
can uncover it is not how long it has
been there it is where it came from the
word of God is God's wisdom it is God's
wisdom and our science and whatever else
it may be it's a human effort trying to
understand what there is and for that
reason whenever our wisdom and our
search does not agree with the word of
God we go by what God has said yes mhm
for instance Hebrews 11:3 through faith
we understand that the worlds were
framed by the word of God notice the
arrangement Faith must come first
through faith we understand understand
the scientific method is let me
understand first then I'll believe let
me see it hear it taste it smell it
touch it let me measure it it is only by
measuring it I know it exists God said
no no no no no believe First what you
can't measure and then true
understanding will come that's why
without faith it is impossible to please
God Amen and faith is the substance of
things not seen the evidence of the
scientists may have a difficulty to deal
with and pastor this Shades light also
on the question of scient speciic
questions that people may run into in
the in the generation we live in should
I believe in science above what God has
said and the answer is we go by what God
has said science cannot be placed above
the Bible the Bible stands over every
bre why that is because Colossians 2:3
Christ is the source of all wisdom and
knowledge you see he is the source of
all if you believe in creation then
Christ is the source of biology he's a
source of sociology the source of Botany
the source of iology the source of every
branch of knowledge except sin Christ
the Creator is the true Source that's
why the fear of the Lord is the
beginning of knowledge start with God
the source of all knowledge
amen we'll take um another question uh
about the uh fifth to 10th commandment
yes do these Commandments exist in
heaven and do they relate to the angels
and the Heavenly beings The Ten
Commandments are the 10
commandments they among the functions
they they they fulfill one is to Define
sin 2 Peter chapter 2:4 for if God
spared not the angels that sinned they
sinned because they violated the law of
God one or more of the Ten Commandments
now we have limited Minds
we may not understand how Commandments 5
through1 function before sin occurred
but the law of God has always been the
law of God because it is an expression
of who he is and who he is does not
change so we with our limited
understanding because of sin our minds
are corrupted in the sense that we don't
understand what Adam would have
understood before he sinned so we think
wait a minute Commandments 5 through1
cannot apply but yes they apply apply in
a way we do not understand they do apply
because the only way to sin on heaven in
heaven or on Earth is to violate the law
of God and the law of God is 1 to 10 not
1 to 4 1 to 10 amen and when they asked
Jesus the question which is the greatest
command he gave Thou shalt love the Lord
your God with all your heart with all
your might uh-huh then he says the
second one is love your neighbor as
yourself these two are based on one
principle love and God is love yes you
cannot do away with one and exonerate
the other that's right that's right amen
the first five the first four your
relationship with God the next six
relationship with those around yes but
they are inseparable because you can't
love God if you don't love your fellow
man whom you see 1 John chapter 5 you
can't do it so they're Inseparable even
though one is higher than the other
because God always comes first he that
love a father and mother more than me is
not worthy of me so the first four yes
they come first your relationship to God
because it is your relationship to God
that enables you to deal properly with
your neighbor if you do not understand
God you may not treat your neighbor the
right way an understanding of God is the
foundation stone on which we understand
everything else the right way amen they
are all built from the same
principles the next question is about
holding Church business discussing uh
Church finances on Sabbath based for
instance on Isaiah 58 is it right to do
business meetings and discuss finances
touch Finance on Sabbath all right God
let's pray again father as we continue
this session very important work give us
wisdom father in Jesus name I pray
amen God gave us seven days he made
seven days he gave us
six one is reserved for strictly holy
activities the other six for secular
activities God gave Adam and Eve
work if God gives you a gift it is good
but they were not to do it on the
Sabbath even though it was given by God
it is good it was to develop character
but they were not to do it on Sabbath
because even good honest work is
inappropriate for the Sabbath a business
meeting is necessary part of the church
life it does not have to be conducted on
the Sabbath what I have observed and
this is not the result of a scientific
survey but what I have observed we are
not willing to give God time Sunday
through Friday so we lump everything on
the Sabbath and we say if it is church
Church business it is suitable for the
Sabbath but mowing the lawn in the
church is church business painting the
church is church business no one would
think of doing that on the Sabbath day
and so business discussions Financial
discussions are fine not for the Sabbath
it is a different day the same way God
is different Isaiah
40:25 who is to whom then will he liken
me or shall I be equal there is no one
like me says God and there is no day
like the Sabbath we ought to have a view
of the Sabbath that causes us to look
closely at any activity that we may
consider doing on God's day to make sure
it it really it fits these church
activities there are 100% good and
necessary for the life of the church but
not necessarily suitable for the Sabbath
we must give God time during the week
because those six days are really his
still it's like the tithe will you have
$100 God says give me 10 but the other
90 still belong to God you follow me and
so we have Friday of Sunday to Friday to
do all these things leave God's Sabbath
alone especially dedicated for worship
and services of that kind thank
you related to Sabbath is the question
of voting mhm is is it okay to vote on
the Sabbath now the church cannot decide
when voting is
scheduled we have to ask ourselves is
voting a holy activity or a civic
duty I don't see how we can describe
voting as a holy activity but it is a
necessary
activity the the Christian understands
that ultimately God is in charge of
what's going on Daniel 4: 17:
25:32 the most high ruleth in the
kingdoms of men Daniel 4 verse uh Daniel
4:35 I think it is where uh that the
Bible says he doeth according to his
will in the armies of heaven and among
the inhabitants of the earth God does
whatever he wants Daniel 1:1 and2 God
gave jeim into Nebuchadnezzar's hand I'm
trying to say God does whatever he wants
so if a day is scheduled for voting it's
on the Sabbath I can't vote that does
not mean that God is not in control of
what's Happening he is still in Ultimate
control and that gives the Christian
Peace of Mind well I'm not voting why
it's on the Sabbath and I cannot
demonstrate how it is a holy activity
not every good thing is Holy as I said
earlier work was given by God it is not
fit for the Sabbath so it's not a holy
activity but it's good and so we must be
very rigorous is this holy
activity if we cannot demonstrate from
scripture it is or we have no guidance
from the spirit of Prophecy then we
ought to avoid it knowing that God is in
final
control not us he sets up Kings and he
Abes them he sets up Kings Daniel 2:21
he puts them down not by my vote even
though voting is a an important uh Duty
for the citizen but it is God who sets
up Kings and puts them down not by my
vote but let me say again vote if it's
not on the Sabbath now there's some
people who say elaw said go vote on the
Sabbath and go to church no someone said
he heard her say that but there's no
direct statement from El white that say
she said go V and someone said he heard
now that if you're a scholar you can't
use that as
evidence did she say that directly no
one can prove that there's no record to
it there's no record
one more on uh the
Sabbath this is uh based on Genesis 1
and 2 the account of creation mhm why is
there no evening and morning on the
seventh day very interesting question
very observant
question Days 1 through
six stress what's done on that day and
also stress the duration of those days
evening morning the seventh day Sabbath
does not stress duration is stresses
quality are you with me now the fact
that evening and morning is not said for
the S the seventh day does not mean it
didn't apply because how else can you
keep the Sabbath because we know from
Deuter uh Leviticus
23:32 from even un even shall you
celebrate your Sabbath what is that even
to even evening and morning now if you
look at the first day of creation
Genesis 1 from verse three and God said
let there be light and there was light
and God saw the light that it was good
and God divided the light from the
darkness and God called the light day
and the Darkness he called night now for
day one it says and God saw the light
that it was good okay but it does not
say and it was so but on day two verse 6
and God said let there be a firmament in
the midst of the waters and let it
divide the waters from the waters and it
was so and God so we have it was so but
it does not say it was good on the
second day and so we have some days on
five of the six days it was good on I
think five of the six of creation it and
it was so but you read verse 31 now
because you have to reason and God saw
everything that he had made and behold
it was very good so even though it was
very good does not show up on day two it
applies you follow me we must reason use
this then we study the word of God
because the Bible has evidence not proof
proof does not require study there's a
lion there's a lion why am I thinking
but if I see a paw print if I see some
fur on the fence if I see wait a minute
n that PO the size of the PA tells me
that's a lion or tiger and then and then
you start following the evidence a big
cat Walk This Way that's dealing with
evidence honestly and so yes the evening
and the morning with the with the
seventh day is not recorded but it
applies because elsewhere in scripture
we're told from even unto even shall you
celebrate your Sabbath Leviticus
23:32 and Mark 1:32 tells us at even
when the sun was set even is sunset an
entire day even to even the dark part
first the bright part first the dark
part begins with sunset the light ends
with sunset the sth day Sabbath is
covered by evening and morning but it's
not written reason come now let us
reason next
question there's somebody who's dealing
with the Farming Farming yes and uh the
question they have is as far as eating
uh produce from these animals they have
arrived at a point where they don't want
to eat say milk or uh eggs from their
chicken but is it okay for this
Christian to continue selling this to
others in the community to who will buy
it yes even when they themselves have
decided they don't want to continue
eating you cannot transfer your convic
ition to somebody
else the people in the community can
show from the Bible that it's fine to
eat a chicken or or a no not a horse or
cow or sheep you see or deer they can
show it's clean food you cannot impose
your conviction on someone else here's
somebody poor and starving you can give
them some eggs you refuse to because I
am convicted that you shouldn't eat
it God doesn't convict me what you
should do God convicts me what I should
do yes we know the ideal diet is a
plant-based diet it goes back to Eden
but Paul tells us in Galatians chapter 1
from verse1 15 but when he pleased God
who separated me from my mother's womb
when it pleased God not when it pleased
the church to stop Paul from killing
Christians when it please God and God is
pleased at different times regarding
different circumstances in different
people's lives a conviction from God is
an individual thing and I cannot require
you to be convicted as I am I cannot do
that now I would not give you pork
because it is clear from the Bible do
not eat the swine I will not give you an
animal that does not divide the hoof and
chew the cud at the same time I wouldn't
do that because there's proof don't do
that but if it's a clean food and
there's someone hungry yes give it to
the person don't impose your conviction
on someone
else very well and the reason I do not
sell um pigs is because the Bible say
says theyan yes direct and I do not have
the same ground for chicken or sheep
or even though the ideal diet MH is
plant-based but even El white himself
tells us in some countries you do the
best you can because you may not have
all that's required to follow vegetarian
diet we must be reasonable right and not
let our personal conviction become
somebody's yes we do that too much MH
and so we Poli people but we mustn't do
that amen okay uh we do have a question
uh pertaining to Jesus's death yes did
Jesus raise himself from the dead or did
his father raise him up Let the Bible
tell us John chapter 10 from verse 16
other sheep I have which are not of this
fold them also I must bring and they
shall hear my voice and they shall be
one fold and one Shepherd therefore do
my father love me because I lay down my
life that I might take it again Verse 18
no man taketh it from me I lay down of
myself and I have power to lay down and
I have power to take it up again this
commandment have I received of my father
now John chapter 2: 211 19-21 Jesus said
destroy this Temple and in three days
I will raise it up again in three he
meant his body Jesus had to conquer
death or he could not have been our
savior he had to conquer death in order
to conquer the curse which is death if
the father had raised him the father
would have conquered death not
Jesus even though the Bible says several
places the father raised him the father
raised him this is written because he
came up at the command of the Father
John 2 verse uh John 10:18 this
commandment have I received from my
father the father told him when to lay
down your life when to take it up it
must be voluntary on both sides I
voluntarily down my life and I
voluntarily pick it up so yes Jesus
raised
himself that's why he has victory over
death hell sin the grave and Satan if
someone else had raised Jesus Jesus
would not have conquered death so
despite the many verses that say the
father raised him it simply tells us he
came up at the command of the father at
the request of the
father and when that you see genuine
obedience is God's work let me say that
again slowly when we genuinely obey God
that is considered God's work in
US Jesus obeyed the father here's what
he said in uh John
14:10 believest thou not that I am in
the father and the father in me the
words that I speak unto you I speak not
of myself but the father that dwelleth
in me he doeth The Works he did it
through The Obedience of Jesus Christ so
when Jesus healed a leper it was the
father doing it through Christ it was
the father's work in Jesus because Jesus
came to show this is what the father is
like so when the father told him to come
up he came up in obedience to the father
and it is considered the father's work
but it was Christ who raised himself if
or if he hadn't raised himself we would
have a savior who needs
help he has the Bible says in Hebrews
chap 1 verse three when he had by
himself purged our
sins Jesus raised himself yeah he at the
command of the father he had the power
to take it back thank
you next is about um the Apocrypha books
yes is it okay for a Christian to read
the books of the Apocrypha such as Enoch
and makab yes it's fine we read
encyclopedia branica some people read
Harry Potter we read all sorts of things
it is fine to read them as long as you
understand they're not considered part
of the Christian Canon but some have
historical information like the mccabes
very very valuable information about
life in the inter testamental period and
the macban Revolt in the second century
uh BC yes they're valuable in that sense
but not doctrinally they are not
considered a part of the Christian Canon
now they included in the Catholic Bible
the Catholics call them detheroc
canonical books like a second Cannon but
as Adventists we know about the Catholic
church and uh what it believes and what
it does it is not a part of the
Christian cannons but they may be read
because they're just books they may be
read yes don't be afraid but they're not
biblical simple as that they can't hold
the same Authority no they don't the
canonical books MH and when you read
some of them you'll be astonished what
you're finding out in some of those book
I mean just as you should shake your
head the things they say all right next
question thank
you the question that we have next is
regarding to the close of
probation for whom does probation close
first now the Bible says in Romans No 1
Peter
4:17 the time is come that judgment must
begin at the house of God now we are in
the time of the
the day of atonement which is the day of
judgment it began October 22
1844 and this is a long subject and I'm
dealing with a few seconds mhm when a
person is examined and a decision is
made based on the person's confession
and then you look at the person's life
based in all the records God have when
that decision is made that that person's
probation is closed whether negatively
or positively in the sense you know
Revelation 2211 he that is unjust let
him be unjust still he that is Holy let
him be holy still there's a judgment
going on now it begins in the house of
God but there's no need for it to begin
outside because outside ERS have made no
confession of Christ you understand so
they've already judged
themselves by rejecting Christ they've
judged themselves so the issue for them
is just the degree of punishment not
whether or not they'll be saved but when
you say I'm a Child of God where God has
to examine that claim you see did your
life measure up to your profession
because profession places people in the
church a profession of Faith but conduct
and character deter whether the person
is connected to Christ so we have
profession then we have behavior and God
looks to see do they correspond but if
you've not accepted Christ you rejected
Christ you have nothing to do with God
there's no need to have a judgment
you've condemned yourself John 3:19 this
is the condemnation that Christ is
coming into the world but men love dark
light is coming to the world men love
dark we judge not we those who do not
accept Christ they judge
themselves mhm so yes in a certain sense
you may say begins at the house of God
because those who've made that
profession are dealt with first amen and
this also has to do with who has to
receive the light the days of
ignorance WIS and God will deal with
that right by the way ignorance must
have two components I did not know and I
had no way of knowing that's ignorance
in the eyes of God okay so judgment in
this case begins with those who have no
ex yes and made a clear confession of
faith those who professed to know the
truth and believed in God and God
examines your life you know that's where
faith and works come in let's God loses
your Works to determine the genu of your
faith you say you my child let's look at
is your life square with the
law
MH
okay we have another question this is
based on Galatians 4 mhm what you
computed may follow the yes go ahead
based on galatian
4 are the Ten Commandments part of the
whole law that God gave through Moses
without going to Galatians 4 the
question is the law of God or the Ten
Commandments part of the law of God God
gave to Moses the 10 commandments are
separate from the ceremonial
law when Lucifer sinned in heaven long
before Adam and Eve were made before
this world was made he violated the law
of God there was no ceremonial law when
Lucifer sinned 1 John 3:8 he that
committeth sin is of the devil for the
devil sinth from the beginning we know
sin is not imputed where there is no law
uh Romans 5:12 Romans 4:15 Romans 3:20
they say virtually the same thing by the
law is a knowledge of sin the fact that
Satan's sin tells us there was a law but
not the ceremonial law that began in the
garden when God provided courts of skins
for Adam and Eve Adam had to kill the
animal even though it's not not
explicitely mentioned and God made the
courts of skins the ceremonial law is
not the moral law by the way people call
the ceremonial of the law of Moses all
the laws came from God the Ten
Commandments God spoke out loud all the
Israelites heard him at the same time
that's very significant the ceremonial
law he just spoke directly to Moses
Moses wrote them then he told them so
all the laws are from God but Moses is
viewed as the lawgiver because it was
given to him but the Bible tells us
clearly I think it's James 4:12 there is
one lawgiver who's able to save and
Destroy one not God and Moses one and
that is God himself and so the Ten
Commandments are the law of God they are
Eternal the ceremonial laws were
temporary they no longer apply because
Christ Our Passover is crucified for US
1 Corinthians 5:7 they no longer apply
no need to kill animals and do whatever
else they were supposed to do but the
moral of God will last forever why it is
based on the character of God and God's
character does not change he's the same
yesterday today and forever but the law
of God we have the ceremonial we have
the moral the ceremonial the ceremonial
no longer applies the moral law applied
before there was sin it applies now
it'll apply after there's no sin
okay thank you our last one is about the
Holy Spirit how can how does somebody
grieve the Holy Spirit of we get a big
clue in Genesis 6:3 the chapter that
introduces us to the flood my spirit
well we read from verse one and it came
to pass well let's pray again father as
we come to the close continue to give us
wisdom God in Jesus name amen amen and
it came to pass when men began to
multiply on the face of the Earth and
daughters were born unto them that the
sons of God saw the daughters of men
that they were fair and they took them
wise of all which they chose we have
this inter Maring a clearly identified
crime against God by the way of all the
evils in the days of Noah that's the
only one clearly identified and the Lord
said my spirit shall not always strive
with man for that he also is flesh yet
his day shall be 120 years and so
Genesis 61 to7 describe the
wicked verse 8 we have Noah brought in
but Noah found Grace so we have the
wicked they're the ones who resist the
pleadings of the Holy Spirit my spirit
shall all he's striving he's striving
he's striving he does not strive with
someone who cooperates you understand
there's no need he strives with those
who keep
resisting Ephesians 4:30 grieve not the
spirit of God whereby you sealed unto
the day of redemption you grieve by
resisting the spirit's pleading you see
it's his job to convict your sin the
conviction comes we resist it comes we
resist that's grieving the spirit of God
and based on Matthew 12
31-32 we also grieve the spirit by
attributing his word to the devil so
when Jesus healed a man who is D deaf
and dumb Matthew
1222 the Pharisees said he does that by
the power of
beelze that's blasphemy against the Holy
Spirit and in verse 36 Jesus said Every
Idle word that men shall speak they
shall give an account the idle word was
this fellow do not cast out Devils but
by be elzea the prince of devil that was
the idle word they attributed God's work
to the power of Satan that's a terrible
accusation against God that's part of
grieving and blaspheming the spirit of
God so we resist his
pleadings and we call his work the work
of
Satan all of which all of which have to
do with the rejection of the guidance of
the spirit of God in our lives yes yes
you see the carnal mind does not like
Divine guidance that's why God has to
renew our mind somehow the we're born
opposed to spiritual things that's where
we're born so God has to do something in
us even before we come to Christ he has
to do something in us which is a
remarkable expression of Grace we are
born opposed to God's law Romans 8:7
and9 we're opposed to God's law by
Nature so it's by God's grace he he does
something to wake us up to the fact look
I'm offering you salvation then you have
to choose but if he doesn't doesn't wake
you up you are dead to spiritual things
I mean dead so Ephesians 2:1 you have he
quickened who were dead a dead person
knows nothing Christ has to wake you up
at some level so that you become aware I
need to choose Christ you can say no but
he must somehow wake you up and as he
does this I desire decide to resist his
guidance you eventually I grieve the
holy spirit because the act of Reviving
you is done by the spirit mhm M the
spirit of Grace the spirit of Life the
spirit of Truth M yes so that brings us
to the end this session yes my pastor
and uh you could um close us off with
the word of before I do let me urge
those who are listening the Bible is a
simple book to understand if we study it
honestly there must be honesty when
studying the Bible keep in mind you
still have the carnal mind now it's no
longer in control because you're child
of God but is still alive that's why gal
s is it 5:1 17 the flesh lusteth against
the spirit and the that goes on until he
that is righteous let him be righteous
still and so the carnal mind is trying
to confuse trying to provide
justification for disobeying God keep
this in mind as you study but also keep
in mind John 17 John
7:17 If any man will do his will he
shall know the doctrine a willingness to
obey God is absolutely essential to
understand truth if you go to the Bible
to to find reasons to disobey the devil
will show you what you're looking
forh because he tried to use scripture
in Psalm 91 you see and he use he tried
to use it on Jesus Christ you see but
Christ knew the word go to the Bible to
say God what do you want me to
know don't go looking for reasons to
support your claims go to be taught and
Ed you do that and God will speak to you
amen all right let's pray Father in
heaven we thank you for this glorious
privilege of trying to make biblical
things simple to those listening I pray
that the spirit of truth will work on
every listening mind de God so that
someone will decide to be honest with
you just lay down all the oppositions
and surrender the will to your hand this
is the beginning of a blessed life bless
all the families that listen a double
blessing on all the children father in
Jesus name we pray amen amen